welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navaro and this is film
ranks where we create the definitive
authoritative top five ranking list that
will live on in infamy for an eternity
until the end of time today we're
delving deep into the unexpected the
Eerie and the downright terrifying
moments that have left an indelible mark
on our minds prepare to be taken aback
because today's ranking is the top five
horror scenes in a non horror film these
are the moments that caught us off guard
made our pulses race and left us peeking
through our fingers these scenes prove
that fear can lurk in even the most
unexpected corners of Cinema we had
guests Eric Voss and Tommy Beal come in
to help us create this list that's pod
raising W the three of us locked
ourselves in the breakroom for an
intense round of deliberation and
exposure therapy of our childhood
traumas and I don't know how I put this
over the Polar Express we gave our El
strict rules and parameters Queen
B I don't know what including defining
what constitutes a non-horror film and
we forced ourselves to open our minds to
dissent while eliminating personal
sympathy votes it's almost like did I
dream that we carefully weighed several
options including polls of our viewers
to arrive at the final definitive
ranking you try to date a cartoon
they're not going to let
you man speaks from experience if you
love rankings like these and want to see
the live version where we came up with
this list head over to our breakroom
channel so grab your popcorn and dim the
lights because things are about to get
seriously
spooky at number five we've got peewee's
big adventure and the terror of Large
Marge and when they finally pulled the
driver's body from the Twisted burning
wreck it look like
[Music]
this that's right who who could forget
Large Marge into this otherwise
Whimsical and silly 1985 comedy where we
follow the childlike and innocent
character of PeeWee Herman as played by
the legendary Paul Rubin director Tim
Burton infused this moment of abject
Terror where we see the face of a truck
driver known as Large Marge go from old
lady to Childhood nightmare fuel within
a couple of frames peewee's CrossCountry
search for his beloved bicycle took him
through a series of absurd Misadventures
to meet a Cavalcade of wild characters
from learning there's no basement at the
Alamo to a Chase through the WB lot from
a fugitive on the lamb to performing for
a bunch of bikers each of them is
memorable in their own way but nothing
hits quite as hard as Large Marge the
stop motion animation effects look
familiar that's because it's done by the
now legendary Cheeto brothers who went
on to create effects for UHF Ernest
Scared Stupid elf Team America World
Police and the critters franchise as
well as their very own film Killer
Clowns from outer space remember that
one I do the prec CGI handmade quality
of the moment only lends to the
surreality of the scene and catches both
Peewee and the audience off guard
effectively subverting expectations and
infusing an element of horror into the
story the result is probably the best
jump scare in a comedy film maybe even
in any film yeah Large Marge is what
taught us to who Tim Burton was and then
we never trusted him after that at
number four we've got the Wizard of Oz
and those damn flying
monkeys take special care of those Ruby
sippers I want those most of all now fly
[Music]
fly look upon them ye viewers and
despair these winged Abominations of the
Wicked Witch of the West are the grizzly
Minions that blindly carry out the
bidding of their dark master swooping in
to terrify poor Dorothy gaale played
wonderfully by a young Judy Garland at
her best they chase what is historically
one of of the cutest dogs ever they
frighten the poor Cowardly Lion they
bully the Tin Man they rip apart the
Scarecrow they rip him apart in front of
all of his companions that is damn and
this is a movie famously for kids the
1939 film based on the 1900 book of the
same name by L frank balm it also lose
the L it's cleaner was one of the first
to use color and was both a critical and
box office success in what is commonly
seen by film historians as one of the
Great greatest years for film with Gone
With the Wind Mr Smith Goes to
Washington and Stage Coach all coming
out that year now to be fair the flying
monkeys are not the only scary part of
this film there are the trees that tear
at Dorothy and her witless heartless
cowardly friends the Wicked Witch
melting into the floor but there is
something just Plum spooky about these
Ariel simeons that has stuck with
audiences and made them iconic for 80
plus years there's no place like home
at number three we've got Willow and
that horrifying Pig
[Music]
transformation that's right they're all
pigs at least according to the
transformation spell of the evil bav
Mora they are in a warwolf movie like an
American Werewolf in London you expect
to see scenes of body horror when the
wolf rips through the human form you are
ready for it uh arguably that's why some
even wanted to see the film to see the
predatory wolf rip out of the feeble
human skin but this
an entire Army turning into pigs this
visceral scene full of strong militant
humans reduced to screaming writhing
masses results in all of them turning
not into supernaturally powerful
Predators but into prey stripped of
their Humanity in an unequivocal
reversal of
power as with most of our films on this
list this is not the only frightening
moment in this film this 1988 classic
from Ron Howard is actually filled with
pretty disturbing moments a horrifying
Hydra likee Dragon that grows more heads
as you chop them off trolls dripping
into a Grizzly slime this dude and these
guys so this film is already full of
some truly gruesome moments which is
what makes this moment even more
horrifying into the context of this
movie a world of evil and grime and
Decay where it seems that there is no
possibility for Sunshine and that evil
will always win so Bleak and dark we
still have even more hope to lose
because even a creature as innocent and
newborn to the world as a baby can be
corrupted and affected by the reach of
the evil of the world so when Willow is
able to prove the might of his magic to
overcome the perception that small
people can only make small contributions
and return the entire Army back to their
human forms they prove that bab Mora is
no match for them and it makes it all
the more satisfying to see her defeated
in the end just a quick friendly
reminder to like And subscribe to new
rock stars and smash the bell for
notifications and please leave a comment
below One does not simply walk into
Mordor at number two is Lord of the
Rings The Fellowship of the Ring where
Bilbo fullon Golems out to hold it again
one last
time that's right large Mar made us jump
then laugh but this jump scare where
Frodo's sweet elderly Uncle Bilbo goes
full golum is quite possibly the biggest
scare in all time in any nonh horror
film and it's not followed by a shocked
laughter but a feeling of for boing and
doom the message here is evident even in
the safest most beautiful and defensible
Haven in all of Middle Earth that of
rivendel and even with the sweetest of
souls that of Frodo's Larger than Life
Uncle the wise play playful and loving
Bilbo can be Twisted by Temptation
corrupted so deeply that a monster can
take root and lunge for beloved family
members in other words no one is
entirely safe from the malevolence and
rot of this ring Peter Jackson was a
horror director before he tackled this
gigantic fantasy story and that
experience certainly shows here the now
iconic film series is still one of the
most ambitious Productions ever
accomplished and single-handedly
catapulted the film economy in New
Zealand putting it at the top of the
list for the most idilic film locations
ever in making Peter Jackson's special
effects and props facility WETA at the
top of everyone's list for
collaborations honorable mentions before
we get to number one here are some other
scenes that if we're being honest have
also given us the he GBS in Superman 3
when the villain Vera steps into that
chamber and becomes a cyborg body Horror
in a Christopher reev Superman film no
thank
[Music]
you
this in the MCU we've seen some great
moments that were sort of scary but into
this mostly familyfriendly franchise we
also have the outlier Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness where we
watched as a beloved hero Wanda maximoff
went fullon Scarlet Witch twisting her
body and cracking her bones to
infiltrate the inner sanctums of Kamar
Taj come on Sam Ry no woo and finally
from our community poll Return to Oz and
those damn creepy
wheelers no just
no and now our number one scary scene in
a nonh horror film at number one the one
and only Who Framed Roger Rabbit when
judge Doom reveals himself Remember me
Eddie when I killed your brother I
talked just
wa it's just supposed to be a bunch of
silly cartoon characters goofing with
each other each other but then comes
Christopher Lloyd we first get the
horror of seeing judge Doom flattened by
a steamroller classic cartoon stuff but
then we see the evil judge Doom pop
right back up a distorted inhuman
two-dimensional being his eyes red
bulging and bloody daggers and then that
voice that haunting cackle that
earpiercing Sinister squeak just
wait as it's revealed that the very
human judge Doom character is actually
very much a c ton character and it
doesn't help that Christopher Lloyd
plays the whole thing with a sadistic
Glee this now classic 1988
live-action/animated comedy from Robert
Zas reveled in the wacky all throughout
the groundbreaking film accomplished a
couple of Feats previously thought
difficult for one it obviously Blended
live action and animation seamlessly
with scenes like this one and this one
but just as interesting is that Warner
Brothers and Disney played nice with
each other allowing Mickey Mouse to
coexist with Bugs Bunny Donald Duck to
coexist with Daffy and for their
Creations overall to live in a shared
Universe in a film that is generally a
light-hearted affair for children that
sure skirted with Darkness the reveal of
Judge Doom stands out as a spine
tingling Revelation that has plagued the
memories of every kid that's seen it on
the whole it's a pretty surreal and
gruesome scene for a family film man
the80s were
great and that is our top five ranking
for horrifying moments in n on horror
films this list as promised will live on
in infamy for an eternity until the end
of time as the definitive authoritative
list but if you want to see how we came
up with these rankings check out the
film ranks discussion over on our
breakroom Channel and don't forget to
leave a comment did we forget any
moments do you feel our ranking should
be in a different order let us know and
maybe just maybe your moment will make
it into a future video for now this has
been this week's film ranks I'm Hector
Navaro signing off so I can go watch a
movie with only soft moments maybe up
pixars up yeah that's just a sweet easy
animated film with no tear jerking
moments right right
[Music]
bye